[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link it's live that VidCon and this
is also our 100th ear biscuits so it's
very special to be sharing it with all
of you guys live and of course everyone
else is just listening mythical beast
who's listening with your biscuit in
ears right now in the comfort of your
own well you don't know where they're at
don't make assumptions about where
they're at driving driving on a on a on
a beautiful scenic cliffside you're
gonna keep going
highway keep your eyes on the road and
your ears on us you were a little bit
late mm I was coming out I wanted to
meet in the middle and do something
interesting I know and then I was just
running yeah running to catch up but I
see you brought your computer so did I I
brought my laptop there's some questions
on the left yeah thank you to everybody
who submitted questions we're going to
try to get through as many as we can but
we we just really like to talk and it's
very difficult for us to get through
many so we're gonna move at a faster
pace than we normally do hopefully
should make promises and this is a round
table it's not exactly ours but I'm
comfortable enough with its roundness
it's not very dim though you guys are a
little dim we're not as dim as we'd like
to normally be when we do this kind of
thing so it may get a little awkward but
it's because we're we're still going to
speak intimately let's get to some
questions yeah let's do that link so are
you
that dude he just said I was amazing oh
oh you know what you're amazing to us
right I'll bounce a little bit of that
compliment over to you okay here's a
question from mythical Samantha if y'all
could be anything for a day what would
you be and why so I could be anything
for a day sorry I need to drink from
this cleared out link clear let's get
brandish jar it's not for sale you know
is it I am alone okay you should plug it
then I think I would be a snake for a
day have you seen a move yeah how many
times furthermore you can you scare
people just by being you but I think we
can I think we can probably do this if
you if you want to get in a sleeping
back and have me tape you up and you
could just slither around I mean we that
can be arranged
you wonder if you really want to know
what it feels like to be a snake I can
help you with that you wonder how we
come up with episodes of good mythical
morning this is it yeah if I could tape
you up I mean a little duct tape in the
sleeping bag goes long ya know what we
have been in a sleeping bag together I
think actually on our show not like
personal time or like last night yeah no
we have separate rooms right separate
rooms and beds my family's here yeah my
family didn't want to come more of my
family is coming into town so my family
didn't want to come down here we knew
when you stumble upon a snake like the
other day on the set of a buddy system
there was a big crowd of people I was
that oh I'm a my in the wrong place
they're shooting there must be shooting
over there so I went over there and then
all of a sudden they're like one of the
guys like pulled up a snake that was
this long and it was one of those non
poisonous types I guess he knew that and
it it would he just he was the most
popular guy in the whole zone and I'd
love to be able to bring that to
somebody it's like you know what if you
got the guts to pick me up you can be
the most popular person in the zone all
right dang that's a weird
reason to want to be a snake so you can
make a dude feel good because he picks
you up in front of a group of people
yeah well you're very you're in him
you're an empath I'm an empath what
would you be
anything I could be anything for one day
I would be the atmosphere I could
experience all things on earth at once
being breathed in and breathed out yeah
farted out - I haven't thought through
this I should have thought about this
before I answer the question I don't
know I think I want to be omnipresent
and guess what I just realized I think I
have God yeah I think I got that wrong
free dance I've got it I'm reading a
book about how the ego is bad though you
should be happy about that
I am happy yeah start applying it then
I'd be really happy next question
penguin in a pumpkin asks how much do
you exaggerate the gross 'no subdued for
entertainment this is a question that
many of you may have wondered about i
actually have a friend of mine who well
okay my friend of mine she teaches a
Pilates class that i'm in don't be
printed with your Pilates instructor
well I just that's obvious trying to
want that kind of over I'm just trying
to cover okay so my Pilates instructor
who's just total Pilates and - has
children enough right and she was
talking about oh I finally figured out
what you do my kids showed me your
videos cuz you didn't tell her no I
don't have an ego I don't tell people
what I do I just want to be the
atmosphere I don't have an ego I just
want to be omnipresent I I told what
just throughout the earth not the
universe okay so I I told her it so
she's like we were watching one of your
episodes where you ate something fill in
the blank whatever and my kids were like
oh it's so gross can you believe they do
that and she was like and she's like a
former actress so she's kind of done the
showbusiness thing and she was like guys
this is entertainment they're not
actually eating that she got into an
argument with her kids about whether or
not we actually eat the things that we
eat she was like they don't have to
think about it they don't have to eat
the things because the people watching
can't smell it they can't see it you
guys could probably retch things up on
command right and I was like we couldn't
get away with that it's all real and she
still doesn't believe me
yeah and I'm thinking huh maybe maybe
she's on herself I was like yeah right
exactly I was like because we we do it
yeah we do we we go all the way yeah the
difference and I think that's the
difference between traditional
entertainment and internet tainment is
that we I mean I'm sure obviously some
people fake internet videos that doesn't
happen right but no but we just we never
crossed our minds that we wouldn't
actually do it for real but I think you
guys would know if we weren't doing it
for real I think you'd pick up on it
well I I have to I have to bring all of
my my acting efforts together and bond a
little up and save it for the summer
when we do when we do buddies rested I
can't waste any any acting ability on
anything else right we don't have a
whole lot to go around right you have to
concentrate it and spew it out during
the summer right so then the rest of the
year I just legitimately spew stuff out
right next question is shall we yeah
this is from Chloe blustery link must be
a fan of yours
how do you know looks just like me and
her yeah what you don't or I con how do
you know when the wisest time is to risk
stability in order to pursue a creative
yet risky dream
mmm risk is in this one twice I don't
know I'm gonna take a risk for a
creative dream right okay so this is
this serious one let's give it let's try
to give a serious answer good serious
well I think for our experience was when
we were presented with a specific
opportunity that we felt like we
couldn't say no - then we it it was a
foregone conclusion we had to we had to
give up something a current job in order
to take that new job opportunity I mean
in retrospect it wasn't it wasn't the
greatest opportunity ever but without
that we wouldn't have gotten to where we
are that opportunity was hosting a show
called online nation in 2007 and we knew
that in order to fly out to LA every
every few weeks and shoot episodes of
this show where we basically introduced
Internet videos we were like Bob Saget
on America's Funniest Home Videos or Tom
Bergeron Tom no but but it now it's who
is it now it's it's Alfonzo Dalton
we're basically Carlton Alfonzo for it
is witty of three generations of AFV
hosts every day I love it when that kind
of thing happens and we were never in
the running for any of them but we were
in the running for a rip-off version of
it on the CW caught online nation which
only lasted a few weeks but we didn't
know that when we we were like we got to
take this job this is like the biggest
opportunity we have we have to actually
be television hosts it's still related
to Internet video which is the thing
we're trying to do but we can't still do
our current job so we had to quit so in
in our minds it was a huge decision but
it was it was it wasn't one of those
things we didn't make the decision then
I think a lot of people in LA makes it's
like okay I want to move out in order to
hopefully create an opportunity and I
you know I respect everyone who makes
those types of choices whether it's
entertainment related or whatever your
dream may
b-but for us I think it was a little it
was later I mean we had we had families
we had we had a lot of responsibility we
just we had a light that we were risky
so it took a lot more to put us over the
edge yeah but I wouldn't say there was a
specific opportunity it wasn't just the
chance to create an opportunity right
but I wouldn't say that it was
necessarily wise so I think that
honestly
so I mean taking a risk isn't always
wise I mean sometimes the wisdom would
be to just stay in whatever is gonna
take care of your family but that's not
always the that's not always the best
decision I mean we did something very
well practically we we weren't gonna do
something that ultimately put things at
risk but it I mean from just a complete
stability and predictability standpoint
we would our lives would be more
predictable and stable if we were still
engineers that's a fact
right absolutely but that doesn't mean
that that was the right thing to do so I
think that and we didn't have a solid
plan B when we took the hosting job on
online nation no because I mean we saw
the writing on the wall when we we saw
the show we're like this is gonna get
canned quick yeah and it right it's not
our fault it was a very bad it's very
very bad I think you can still find some
of that on the internet don't search it
but I think if you search online nation
cancelled there was a video that we made
afterward which basically encapsulate
how we had to immediately start to
figure out what we were doing but I
don't think it's always the wisest
decision I think there's some times that
you you you put yourself in a situation
where you know it's what you want to do
it's not we're not we're not saying
whether it's right or wrong it's just
like I feel like I am made to do this
this is a great opportunity I want to do
this it doesn't necessarily mean that
it's wise it but you still may be the
thing that you should do there's a lot
of people who make those kinds of
decisions in fact the majority of people
who make decisions to drop one thing to
pursue a risky dream by definition don't
succeed at it because it's a risky dream
that's what makes it risky
but it should be a calculated risk and
you should calculate I guess that's part
of the advice is calculate as much as
you can what if you don't know how to do
math hmm well then you're screwed you're
screwed so keep your calculator with you
at all times take calculated risks and
you'll be okay but if there's something
that you can't you you can't not do and
then live with yourself then do it
so you can live try it so you live with
yourself it's I hope that makes sense
it's kind of the same principle that
applies when you're trying to figure out
whether or not you're in love with
somebody and you're like I don't know if
I should be if if we should get married
or you know this relationship should
become more serious it's not like I know
that you like to like sit down and make
like a pro/con I did make a pro/con list
about my I've got my wife at one point
when we were dating I thought do that
and then she found it after we got
married she was like you don't like my
voice why'd you go read that I love your
voice baby it's changed since we dated
it drops
oh god I didn't know I don't know why I
said that
but you can't get to in when you're
talking about passion you're talking
about dreams you just you can't it's not
formulaic it isn't mathematical that's
that's not how life works mmm and if in
if and if you go after something and it
doesn't work then life's not over you
just you restart and you try something
again it doesn't mean that the dream has
to work in order to pursue you know
knowing that it's gonna work that's not
how you figure out whether you're gonna
pursue it or not well we we sacrifice
our jobs to take this new hosting job
then it got canned because it sucked and
then we had this we had to start over
with an entirely new career which was a
key point that we would never have
gotten to do what we're able to do now
right if it wasn't for taking that risk
and then it failing right was all part
of it how about a serious an even more
serious question kaboom fungtastic
asks you like pizza yeah I like pizza
yeah not as much as my wife she loves
some pizza
she bought a float a pool float that's
there was a slice of pizza you can't eat
that no but that's how much she loves
pizza she and she didn't eat it
and it's still around no she ate it no
it we jumped on it three times and yeah
it was gone yeah pool floats and pool
floats don't work in my family Michele
MacNeil asks how long are the new format
gmm episodes gonna be 22 minutes like a
standard TV show
good job tell us more about it we would
be happy to tell you more about that so
this is something that some of you may
have heard about it's been you know
publicly announced in like industry
publications and stuff like that
so maybe you didn't know so GMM is going
to be bigger and better in the fall and
yeah you can cheer for that
so the very cool thing is happening now
there are there are two different
programs that YouTube is doing to help
the creators like us finance content you
know one is YouTube read originals like
buddy system which of course is YouTube
read shows where you pay the monthly
subscription fee and you get all the
YouTube read originals and no ads and
Google music and all that stuff which we
definitely think it's worth it and you
should do but then there's YouTube
originals which is free YouTube just
like good mythical morning is now ad
supported YouTube that they're also
investing into some creators like us to
help us do even more so starting in the
fall we don't know exactly when this
will happen but before the end of the
year we are gonna take GMM to a place
where you're getting more good mythical
morning every single day not just the
one segment like typically right now
we'll do like will it whatever and
that's the episode for that day in the
fall there's gonna be a handful of
things that we do every single day that
you can sit down and enjoy as a
approximately 22 minute experience every
single day but you'll also be able to
enjoy the individual pieces of that so
you guys may remember years ago the
mythical show that we did a half hour
comedy which was I think we did like 10
or 12 episodes of that but it was one
really long video that like a 30 minute
video that you could choose to watch
that or not one of the cool innovative
things that were trying to do with the
new good mythical morning is still give
you that individual video experience you
can be like this video is about this
thing and I can share that but you can
also make the decision every single day
to say I'm going to watch this episode
of good mythical morning which in
reality will be a handful of videos
together
it's another piece of ticker tape wasn't
it great how that was just floating in
the atmosphere now this one this one is
distinctly different than the one we
caught on stage with Susan yeah
this one has a matte finish so now I
know a second clue about the confetti
celebration that will happen at the end
of VidCon there will be both white matte
finished confetti and silver confetti
you sure welcome it also makes a good
oil blotter oil blotter Lily asks will
you bring back characters like rabbit
lightning in the fall when you do some
bigger things with gwm yeah we're
figuring our plan out now you know we're
starting to percolate the ideas but in
general I think our approach is gonna be
we've done so many things you know
character work music
stuffs you know likes music stuff like
songs sketches local commercial we've
done all types of stuff on YouTube over
the years and so we got this just grab
bag this like tool box that we we're
pretty certain we're gonna open back up
and say okay now that now that we have
the opportunity to create more videos
and segments of the show every day okay
know what what can we start putting into
that so it's not maybe everything's not
behind the desk so bringing rabbit
lining back is is a is this distinct
possibility yeah but that is settle it
but we're figuring it all out yeah we're
at this point we know sort of the the
format in terms
that we're gonna do multiple segments
but we're right in the middle of
shooting buddy system we've got another
four weeks four weeks four weeks of
shooting buddy system and while that's
going on it's you know it's the 13 hour
a day everyday basically so there's
nothing else that's happening except
shooting buddy system but as soon as
that is over we may take a short
vacation we're trying to do that and
then we'll get in we'll get back to GMM
as you know it but we'll also get back
to planning what the new GM is gonna
look like I think for us we'd like to do
new projects and good mythical morning
is so important to us and to you guys so
what's particularly exciting about what
we're gonna be doing with GM in the fall
is that it it it's a fresh new approach
to it and it's in I think if we succeed
at kind of turning this corner in turn
in terms of making it bigger and better
and longer I don't know I you know it
maybe it'll shape the face of
entertainment that's a statement in
terms of longer form longer form content
that's that's just out there on YouTube
for everybody to enjoy well I think the
sort of the philosophy behind YouTube's
investment in good mythical morning is
you've got these guys like Jimmy Fallon
Jimmy Kimmel James Corden you know the
late-night guys who write if you go to
the trending page you're gonna see with
the stuff that they've done you're gonna
see carpool karaoke it's gonna go viral
every time James Corden does it and and
they think about tailoring parts of
their show so that you'll watch in his
chair we're on YouTube we know that for
a fact from people who work on those
shows that they think about their show
as it will exist on YouTube it's much
less now about the people sitting down
and watching that the hour-long show
every night and it's much more valuable
and important that they they are
relevant online and that there's pieces
of the show that are going viral so the
idea behind GMM 22 is like okay well
we've we've been in this space for a
number of
years and you know the people who are
also enjoying those videos are enjoying
the things that we're doing but what if
we had not exactly but similar resources
that they do in order to invest in the
stuff that we want to do what could we
accomplish and and and when you think
about it when you think about YouTube
first and they're not it's not just an
afterthought or a thought for pieces of
something hit me with another question
Lenora sure asks how does one stay young
at heart especially as you're nearing 40
years well she left out old but I
appreciate 40 years old she could have
left out the 40 part - yeah I'm not
gonna own that well I'm gonna be there
before you are October 11th
2017 I will turn 40 even the look on
your face right now it's like a look of
an old person like it's like it it - it
overtook you yeah well young at heart
well before we get too young at heart
I will say I have him just at the advice
of well this actually happened the other
day on the set of buddy system the
makeup girl one of the makeup girls
Rachel I stepped into the chair and she
was like we step into our chairs they're
like they're like hot tubs you like have
to crawl inside of it she said you want
me to put some some of these under your
eyes this morning oh I was like what are
the what do you mean these and then she
held him up and there are these little
things that you and I was like do you
think I need them and she said yeah you
could use them she's but we've gotten
pretty close with the with the makeup
and hair he want him to be very honest
with you so it's like so we can have
open honest conversation so she wasn't
being cruel no no she was being artful
she was being very very couple yes you
was because
I'm gonna see I'm gonna you know see
myself on screen and be like why don't
you tell me about the little things that
I could put under my eyes that I didn't
know about so did she put something
under there she did and and then after
that last weekend when I went home she
she gave me something else she gave me a
whole face mask thing oh I got one of
those too dr. Wu yeah I got dr. Wu all
over my face yeah the weekends it's like
a slimy thing with with eye holes in the
nose here I've seen my wife wear those I
didn't know they were for men sexist I
put one I put one on and of course I
have a beard and so it just kind of
attached to the top of my face and in
the bottom just like hung off I look
like a Pirates of the Caribbean like
Yellin I I did the exact same thing and
I come out into the bedroom and I'm like
Chrissy's in there and Lily was in there
and I was like oh they went they weren't
too afraid
but um yeah because of the mustache and
I hadn't shaved it it was like flapping
down here it was like my face was
sloughing off right you know how your
face could slough off yeah I can't that
happened i sat in the in the makeup
chair and I know I was in the hair chair
yesterday and I was shirtless because we
were doing it we were doing a spa scene
and well and Anna had she had turned my
hair because it's supposed to over the
course of buddies didn't has to say the
same length so she has to keep it
consistent yeah and once it took don't
look don't look I should have pointed I
should have pointed
it's literally impossible to catch it
before it hits the ground it doesn't
matter how hard you try we're never
gonna actually catch one is somebody up
there dropping them could a 40 year old
guy do that I didn't catch it I was like
you trimmed my neck when I had my shirt
on but now that my shirts off and you
should got a little lower and then um
she looked at my shoulder my shoulder
blade just like Isis its bump right here
on both of my collarbones yeah and she
she she touched it she said when did
this happen at Birth yeah I was like
born this way yeah it's all just laying
that way man she was like oh my my
brother broke his collarbone and that's
what it looks like yeah it's like a view
you gotta have people in your life who
can just give it to you straight you
know it's like your collet your
collarbone looks janked up like it is
broke right you might need to have some
sort of I don't know some sort of like
get a muscle up there or something so
we're staying young at face because of
dr. Wu shoutout not a sponsor don't
don't even know him or her and but
young-at-heart
would we I think it's all about attitude
yeah I mean if you're gonna have to wear
the face mask or the the bags under the
anti bag thing then you should come out
of your bathroom and go and that evens
it all out yeah well I'll get hard
we actually have there's there's a
chapter in the book of mythicality
available for pre-order actually
available for pre-order at book and
mythicality calm but available and who's
been to the mythical booth okay and
whose pre-ordered the book at the booth
okay so you guys know the cool little
gift pack that you can get you get the
booklet of mythicality you get
like a door hanger and a nope there's
all these cool mythical themes stuff
that you get in this pack if you
preorder here and each one of those
things as you'll see once the book comes
out kind of ties in to a different
aspect of mythicality that we that we
flesh out in the book and one of those
is embracing maturity where we talk
about you know obviously we're not it's
pretty it's pretty clear that we do some
really stupid stuff on good mythical
morning stuff that grown men shouldn't
be doing what is it bad it's a matter of
opinion and that is actually a part I
think that ties into this question
actually this embrace immaturity thing I
think that's one of the ways that we
stayed young at heart is never
completely growing up you got to grow up
and you got to move out of your parents
house okay that needs to happen at some
point you need to take financial
responsibility for yourself we've done
that but if you think and start taking
yourself too seriously and every part of
you grows up like what's the point right
and so there's got to be that party that
remains a child and can unabashedly
enjoy things like bathing and cereal or
ranch dressing or chicken noodle soup
there's been a few things that we bathed
them and that's why we're bathing in
cereal on the cover of the book of
mythicality because we thought that that
was a perfect way to illustrate that
embracing of immaturity that's kind of
the tomfoolery aspect of mythicality
that we want all of our stuff to do we
don't ever want anything we do to be
anybody to get the idea that we take
ourselves too seriously or you want us
that you we want you to take us too
seriously but there's a whole chapter
about that in the book a whole whole
chapter yeah yeah Sam
cactus emoji 17 asks if you had to
describe my cactus emojis are really
going around these days but is that an
emoji I'm not even using the word right
it's an icon it's a picture it's an
internet picture it's an emoji good I
was right
if you had to describe buddy system
season 2 with one sentence what would it
be oh we debated we debated whether or
not we were going to reveal this to talk
about yeah because we haven't talked
about what buddy system season 2 is
about we have not told anyone the
concept when we pick each other we
mentioned everybody who's shooting know
we have with us a lot of who told all
them don't know what's going to see the
script the script is the script exists
but yeah we haven't publicly said what
buddy system season 2 is about we could
tell we're gonna do that right now but
we don't have to tell you but we could
reward the people who came out to the
live year biscuit I think that would be
that would be an appropriate thing to do
and those of you who are listening on
your cliffside Drive who've made it this
far they got to be a cliffside it's
beautiful it's so scenic yeah keep your
eyes on the road so much atmosphere to
the right oh so they're heading south on
the west coast yes on the PCH that's
right of course once you get to LA it
kind of skirts over a little bit so
technically you're looking like Esau
well sounds but you're heading east yeah
because of the shape of California but
then when you get down to San Diego it
kind of starts straightened back out and
then once again you would be looking
east in heading south what were we
talking about but then you get to the
border you got to have your passport
used to be able to not have to have your
passport to get into Tijuana now you got
to have your pass right it's such a
rigmarole we're giving a lot of advice
to this person that's traveling
traveling to Tijuana there's a guy right
now listening to ear biscuits and he's
like at the border crossing he's like
how do they know
he's gripping at his jacket I'm not
going to Teo on announcer turn back
it was a bad idea your brother-in-law
talked you into this head back to the
hotel now let him walk across without
you playing around a golf [ __ ] worked
his name is Stewart Stewart just keep
listening to us we're about to tell you
what's happened in a buddy system season
- don't listen to Joel let Joel go to
Tijuana by himself it's different than
season one in all the ways that you want
it to be different than season one but
not in any of the ways you don't want it
to be different than season one you want
it to be longer
it is Yepez ODE is longer but you wanted
to still have a musical number in each
episode yes it's still going half a song
in every episode
you want me to still be in it boom I'm
gonna still be in it I'm not in it
that's that's that's the difference it's
all about link finally this is the
question that season two seeks to answer
what would it be like if the two of us
had never met as kids but met as adults
so we still meet so don't worry it would
still mean does that sound exciting the
thing that was exciting for us in in
writing it if I just focus on like the
conceptualization part of this thing was
first of all when you have longer
episodes you're able to write more of a
cohesive story so each each episode is
its own journey
I mean it's episodic in that way but
then when you look at the the entire
series it really is about the journey of
our friendship
it's starting from not having one to
wherever it ends up and it's and it's
not that's not a it's not a linear path
right and I I really enjoyed kind of
digging into writing
the relational dynamics between the two
of us I think we're but we were able to
dig into that a whole lot more so it
wasn't just about wouldn't it be funny
if the two of us did this and then did
this and did this but wouldn't it be
interesting if we had conflict in this
way or if we encountered this problem in
this way because the season one it was
the two of us solving one problem
together and in a lot of ways you could
almost interchange you could take those
two and just dissolve them into one
character and you would have this you
could tell the same story that's
definitely not the case in season two
where it's very much
about there being conflict and
resolution and a building of a
friendship between the two of us and we
actually brought in for a number of
reasons one reason was you know we wrote
every bit of season one ourselves to
kind of establish the template of what
buddy system was going to be for season
two going to 22 minute episodes it's
like about 250 260 pages of script which
with everything that we have going on is
we can't do that so we actually brought
in some experienced
show runners and riders to work with us
and we all linked and I sort of
conceptualized the show and what was
going to happen but they had some
experience with helping us find the
conflict and find those moments that I
don't think typically we would have
written because we just are like what's
funny this is funny and that's something
that that's something that they didn't
that's something that happened in the
room with us yeah yeah you know it's not
but they help they help too they were
there okay so what now why would you be
mad and a lot of it was based on things
that are true about us but the
interesting thing is because we are who
we are because we met and when we were
six years old in a lot of ways our
personalities and you know exactly
obviously what we're doing for a living
is very much based on the fact that we
met as kids but it's also you know
whether it's your best friend or your
spouse or a good friend or your family
they shape who you are yeah and if you
were raised in a different place you
would be a significantly different
person so we are kind of exploring one
of the written well the fun one of the
fun things about season two it's like
what would link be like if he never
met me some of the ways that i feel like
i tempered him and vice versa the way
that link tempers me so I think we're in
in one sense we're make each other
better I mean temper so it's like well
what are our what are our flaws as
people that again back to that point
before when you gotta have people in
your life that will tell you like it is
I mean if we were left to our own
devices right that's that's really what
season two is about and there's a lot of
humor that comes out of that and there's
a mustache - yeah I would I would have a
mustache if we were not friends right
and I would have it I think is it in the
BTS video today that I am an by yeah
yeah I have a man bun I'm sorry so we
make some it's not because I think is
cool is because I think I might have one
if I never met Lincoln so anyway it was
it was fun to explore that so I think as
you watch buddy system season 2 you can
there's a lot to learn about what what
we think we could have been if it wasn't
for our friendship and and also a
commentary on the other people that it
just it's a commentary on how people
influence who you become in a good way
computing can bring the best that is in
you you're gonna cry but you're mostly
gonna laugh yeah you're gonna laugh more
than you cried yeah Remy May asks in
three words so as to keep the mystery
what's your favorite plot point in the
new season of buddy system
three words plot point robot nougat
murder I think we just covered at least
three plot yeah yeah that's really three
now two of them are tied actually two of
them are tied both robot and nougat are
tied to murder yes it's a dark season it
really is a press it's it's a little
dark eye and now that we're shooting
this thing cuz I mean that was what
we've thought about writing right now
that we're shooting this thing it's
crazy I mean it's
it's we just we just keep saying this is
crazy this is why are we doing this this
is stupid it's like this is awesome it's
perfect yeah but when other people it's
not perfect I don't know if other people
laugh on set you you feel right about
the choice but then you have to do it
again Braz they laughed yeah and they
have to be quiet okay
Derek Kane asks you do a lot of
experimentation to what do you owe your
curiosity is there someone who nurtured
that in you Derek I appreciate the
question keen and on curiosity as one of
the tenants of mythicality
along with creativity and tomfoolery but
yeah I think who is someone who nurtured
that in us is certainly our friend Ben
from from grade school that we've
mentioned in the past and actually the
book of mythicality is dedicated to Ben
and our friendship with him from grade
school he's no longer with us he passed
away years ago my seven or eight years
ago yes so but Ben was kind of there
were the three of us hung out a bunch
growing up and it was one of those
things this is before the internet and
before phones you bet you had you know
television with a few channels and you
had like your Nintendo at home but Ben
was always encouraging us to go outside
and do something and do something
impossible
you'd be like today we're going to dam
the creek behind my house and then
turning into a fish pond and our
response would always be okay yeah but
we'd be thinking but will you never tell
Ben that be like cuz there's something
about the way that Ben said today we're
going to fill in the blame then by the
end of the day it inspired damn the
creek yeah like three beavers and he
didn't know we could do it we were all
just very curious what would it actually
take today
McCree and then we went and caught a
fish from the pond and brought him put
in a bucket and put them into the fish
pond and then the next day it broke but
yeah we had a damn thing week again but
then he would be like today we're going
to build an a-frame fort and I remember
thinking what has he acted I always
acted like I knew what he was talking
about his laughs a frame yeah that
sounds good yeah one of those a frames
have no idea what he's talking about I
understand now that if you look at it
from the side it's an a yeah but we made
a fort and then he was like we're gonna
make a Stach mud roof with straw and mud
he was like that primitive camping guy
yeah primitive was it caught on the
YouTube channel there's there's a
primitive technology yeah he was like
that that guy is inspired by Benin and
we would do that and then we would like
camp in it that night but then one day
he was like we're going to cut these
stalks of this dried plant and smoke it
protect that was a weird day he got it
there were the economists big joke
George it was like it was like bamboo
that had like a foam inside of it and it
would get dry and he cut it into small
pieces and then we started smoking it
well you I wouldn't say smoke it I would
say we light the end of it was it was
like painting a fan of mine was smoking
no I mean we it what we tried to what
sun breathe it in and it was
uncontrollable coughing and then we're
like we're never doing that again
yes he encouraged experimentation in in
their whole life philosophy is based on
it didn't have to work out no in order
for it to be an experience I mean we'd
go through the woods and you you know
you'd pass these vines hanging from
trees all the time but then he he was
curious and he was like what if we took
my machete which I always carry with you
yeah right and chop the bottom of it and
then we all we were like Tarzan we swing
from every vine between here in the Cape
Fear River right you know yeah so he had
this sense of it
and this this willingness to try
something and to kind of be the one who
came up with the idea and then got other
people to do it
and he kind of he's the embodiment of
mythicality a lot of ways for us so we
dedicated the book to Ben but we
actually didn't talk much about Ben in
the book because we've got a lot of
Ben's stories that we want to save for
something else because there's there's
plenty of stories about us and the
things that we did but a lot of that is
based on that spirit of mythicality that
we would we didn't even understand or
could identify at the time when it was
happening that been exhibited let's see
next question ace Heather snow asked I
love tattoos I have nine good on you
girl want to get another any suggestions
maybe a mythical tattooed love you and
the mythical crew especially Alex a
whole time I'm talking to you guys I
keep accidentally looking at Alex she
didn't even say that though yeah she
does get it because I like Alex she
didn't even say that that's what you get
for being in my line Heather snow loves
you I'm sure she does Anna and the whole
mythical crew you got you got some
tattoos - she's in a - she's got nine
now she's got nine keep up your pace you
may be you can catch up with her man oh
after that one tattoo that I got on my
butt cheek in your presence while we
were making a video of your wife's name
I was like man that hurts yeah
I'm not signing up for that any any
anytime soon again but I've thought
about it if I can have an instant sleeve
you don't want this like that I don't do
it I'd do it
you don't want an instant sleeve why not
cuz you want the process of the sleeves
being filled up yes yeah that's part of
it
cuz you well it's not like you go up to
somebody with the sleeve and you'd be
like is an instant and knowing whatever
ask me so I wouldn't have to explain it
it doesn't look incident
yeah it looks like it would took place
over a period of years right on purpose
that is the input - that got it in one
sitting I think your point is that is
what makes a sleeve cool there's like
the implied investment the journey if
you knew that you could get an instant
sleeve then people would start asking
and you you might have to tattoo
not an instant sleeve as part of your
yeah instant sleeve I can't say that I
recommend mythical themed tattoos
although I definitely appreciate them
and many people have gotten them in fact
I just saw a guy - eat a day or two ago
the GMM logo as I couldn't tell what
part of his body it was on though no no
no no okay it was could have been thigh
it could have been well it's a flea arm
it was too close it was just skin and I
couldn't identify no flame right above
the crack it could have been his butt
but it might lighten a fart yeah
that's called the what's that called
that area the [ __ ] stamp area yeah
don't get it there actually in the book
of mythicality there is a full spread of
me basically naked covered in tattoos
where we go into detail about where you
should get what tattoo well not only
that but what is seven on you what a
tattoo is the intention of a tattoo at
the at the time of tattooing and then
what your grandkids will think about
that tattoo and the conclusions that
they will come to to you about you and
where you're at in life so you're so
we're gonna help you make the decision
on that page of the book just just the
way that the long-term consequences are
thing but I'm particularly fond of one
tattoo there which I'll go ahead and
tell you about because once I looked at
my tattooed body I was like we need
something down here at the bottom on the
foot like the left foot doesn't have
anything that was like tube sock
tattooed hmm
which I'm sure has been done because any
tattoo that you can think of has been
done it's a challenge to come up with a
totally original tattoo is it even
possible huh I don't know don't ask me
but if you did ask me I would say get a
tube sock tattoo so I'm talking about
like you take your sock in your shoe off
and then there's this there's still some
sock there that thing goes all the way
up to like the buckle of your knee add
some stripes look like a basketball
player from this 60s on that one about a
glove tattoo you could also do that how
has Barbara and Jade's relationship
progressed this is from Makeda that's a
great question I think we talked about
this we never remember where we talked
about things but Barbara and Jade are
best friends these are our dogs by the
way they're definitely best friends and
it was not it wasn't forced on them but
they spent a lot of time together at
work and most of the time they've been
together it's just sort of just
aggressively playing so much so that you
can't do anything while they're in the
room together
like if we were barb Barbara and Jade
right now and I'll be Jade I know what
I'll demonstrate cuz I have to like bite
you all over the face I'll be Barbara so
you be Jade and then then I'll come back
over here yeah and then it'll be like
she's not a turkey didn't know if I got
a dog is not a turkey you're saying
gobble
oh man how's how's my hair good gracious
but they they also go to this place
together we must call it a kennel well
but they call it a pet resort yeah it's
it actually has paradise in the name of
it yeah and it's a very nice dog resort
it's got a swimming pool and they go
don't stay there with these other dogs
and you can you can log in and watch
them on the live webcams that they have
so you want to check in on your dog and
like every time you check in Barbara and
Jade are like sleeping next to each
other we I went to pick up who went to
pick up I went to pick him up I went to
pick Barbara and I was like how were
Barbara and Jade and she was like no
that's not what you said because the the
employee just volunteered she's got a
really publish it she's got a good she's
got a good friend here I was like yeah
Jay and she was like oh how'd you know I
was like well they're best friend she
was like oh they've been they've just
been hanging out the whole time and we
didn't know that they knew each other
yeah so they go everywhere together and
they sleep next to each other every
single night I don't mean to keep plug
in the book but I'm just excited about
it what we dedicated a whole chapter to
Barbara and Jade and basically what's
the chapter called risk your heart for
an animal risk your heart for an animal
so yeah you like that we did a photo
shoot with our dogs it's ridiculous
I had a dream the other night that
Christy gave Jade away and I was so sad
she gave Jade away to our neighbor and
in my fear in my dream I was at the
window looking out the window and the
neighbors pulled up in the car and I'm
like oh [ __ ] Jade's in the car with him
they opened the car door and Jade gets
out and I'm like oh yes now this is when
she's gonna run out of the car over here
and come back home to me and so they
opened the door Jade runs out and just
does right in their house and I was so
upset no exaggeration I woke up
oh right like a nightmare you know how
you son
like I never wake up from a nightmare it
never happens to me you know I like woke
up in bed all that good and she some
night she sleeps with us some night
she's on a rotation it's just leap with
Lincoln she'll sleep with lilies just
sleep with me Chris was she there that
night she was not there that cool and I
came this close to getting out of bed
and go any getting her out of Lincoln's
bed but then I just went back to sleep
I was like it's a dream I'm a grown man
yeah but every dream everything that is
revealed in a dream is based on some
real-life insecurity Kristi loves Jade
as much as I do Steve she does not want
to get rid of Jay she hadn't been
dropping any hints no no I think she's
been dropping subconscious hints that
you're picking up on I mean your wife
the only thing we want is the poop that
sometimes she leaves in the house and we
do get angry about and choked up yeah so
they're doing great and their
relationship means so much that there's
that they we made a there's a barber and
JT shirt at the mythical booth right I'm
sorry yeah we got it right here on the
deadly progress of rhett and Link barber
and JP why did Rhett stop saying golly
who asked that you Dan Z why did Rhett
stop scene I'd only I don't remember I
don't remember saying golly who I used
to say it a lot you did I used to say
that a lot
oh yeah you would I'm remembering now
I'm sorry I stopped saying it I'll start
again golly golly yeah does anyone here
remember Rhett ever seen golly it's a
thing oh well when did I stop they don't
know when you stopped two years ago two
years ago yeah must have had some bad
fish
it seems you're like--you're it's
usually where capillary toolbox is
altered permanently from no abyss man
things that you ingest can change your
DNA that's a fact
you get some bad fish it goes in there
it attaches it replicates changes who
you are there's research right now you
wait you'll remember this ten years from
now they'll be talking about bad fish
how it changes what how you talk
that's your vocabulary toolbox yeah
which all you gotta have is some good
fish to get rid of it Oh to reverse it
let's go get some good fish after okay
we will I mean obviously dat Alafia I
don't even care it doesn't have to farm
raised
Oh farm raised you can taste the dirt
you ever noticed that you really can it
tastes a little dirty
tilapia that's been farm raised I put
them in dirt they grow them like
potatoes oh wow yeah that's why this
that's what it tastes like that Sarah in
ATL asked us what are you most excited
about for the hashtag - of mythicality
later this year I'll see you in Durham
North Carolina so uh we got a homecoming
at the end of the tour ticket sales went
really good so people will actually be
there who's gonna be at the tour of
mythicality yeah there there are not
many tickets left I think there's a few
places that still have tickets before we
talk about what we're excited about
we'll say that we wish we could go more
places but 16 different places is about
all we can fit in and still be sane at
this point but hopefully it goes well
and hopefully we will do it again and
get to come to more places and maybe
even outside of the US at some point but
I mean I'm personally excited about we
you know we tend to get very excited
about the next thing that we're doing
right and then kind of putting ourselves
into something and making it into
something that people will remember and
so the tour of mythicality is no
different and it's something that we
haven't done in a long long time we only
never did a tour before
but we haven't really done anything
alive except for the occasional while
we're doing this but the Tour de
mythicality is gonna be a lot different
than this but we haven't done any live
music or any sort of event in a very
long time because the internet sort of
encourages you to create something that
you can just put on youtube and export
out to as many people as possible but so
this is kind of approaching something in
a totally different way from a creative
standpoint again that's something that
we need to plan what we're gonna do
that's another thing we need to get on
that's a good point we just do that
approximately what we're gonna do we
need to come up with specifically what
we're going to do yes I think that's
what we're excited about at this point
is developing something that will
connect with you guys that then I'm sure
will lead to more things that we want to
do creatively everything you do when you
try something new it's like okay we can
add to that or we can do something
different or but right now will its
excited to be the face where it's like
okay we can invent what we want to do on
stage that connects with you guys so
yeah I think that's it and on that note
and in closing I'll say that it is cool
to be here and see your faces and get to
meet some of you guys later on today you
guys are great mythical beasts and those
of you listening on your on your way
back from almost a Tijuana yeah now the
ocean is on your left you're heading
north or west depending on if you're
back up towards LA right yeah but then
if you will straighten back up when you
get around Santa Barbara but yeah this
is this has been very fun I I could not
think of a better way to celebrate the
100th episode of your biscuits than in
this way with you guys taking your
questions and having having a
conversation yeah thank you to to every
one of you who watches our videos and
has become a part of this community you
know the community has grown in ways
that we never expected over the past few
years and there and there were questions
about how do you guys feel about the way
the community is grown and how you
connect with people and is it the same
way that it was 10 years ago well of
course it feels a little bit different
than it did 10 years ago when
or a handful of people that we could
call our fans and we basically knew them
we still know some of those people
personally who were fans of like the
rhettandlink cast live like way back in
the day that's kind of an impossibility
at this point but I'll say one of the
things is that we do know you guys who
are really active in the community who
are talking about GMM and mythical
things on your Twitter and on Facebook
like every in fact everybody as part of
our mythical team like we know those
people who are super active mythical
beasts it's like we see your tweets we
see you guys talk about stuff we see you
say I got this or I got this tattoo or I
just bought this or I'm just excited
about buddy system like we do see all
those things and we see those things
personally we're not always in a
position to respond to everything
personally but we definitely feel the
love and of course it's a very tangible
love right now that we can feel when
we're in the same room with you guys and
that's another thing that we're excited
about is we get to come around meet you
guys today at 5 o'clock and also as we
come around the country in the fall on
the tour of mythicality thank you for
being your mythical best q the
ticker-tape drop
[Applause]
[Music]